well where do human rights come from you
know you can say where do the rights of
the comatose come from or the babies
come from it's the fact that within us
we have a sense of moral purpose and we
know innately most of us whether
something seems right or seems wrong and
we have the rules that we live our lives
by which they do not do such and such to
some individual it may hurt do not be
disrespectful and I think that that has
to extend beyond those we relate to most
because the true test of compassion is
if you can be decent to those you relate
to least so I believe it comes from
within us from where we get kindness
generally and where we're able to be
altruistic to others that's where it we
should extend that
you